- Alors qui est cet homme qui
sera nommé demain directeur
général du Canadien de Montréal
et qui va travailler avec Jeff
Gorton qui est vice-président à
faire hockey.
vous avez joué avec lui comme
vous étiez petit?
- Ça fait longtemps que je n'ai
pas été petit.
On a joué deux ans au niveau
Bantam ensemble et on a joué
dans la région de l'ouest de
Lille alors notre connaissance
notre relation faiêmeêmeêmeêmeêe
un certain temps.
- Il est québécois parce qu'on
voyait sur Twitter des gens,
c'est un québécois québécois, il
parle français, voulu par les
Français?
- Oui c'est un gars qui parle
très bien français c'est sûr
qu'il a un accent mais il parle
très bien français et j'ai
côtoyé plus pendant plusieurs
années dans les arénas et on
parlait français avec les gens
qui nous entouraient alors c'est
un gars qui s'expriment très
bien dans la langue de Molière.
- Il travailla Bostan enfin Gohr
tu ne le connais bien alors on
peut penser que depuis le jour
un c'était son choix, qu'est-ce
qu'un agent de joueur peut venir
apporter aux Canadiens?- Ceci aa
négociation je pense que c'est
un atout on est capable de bien
négocier c'est comme si l'agent
passe dans le camp et demie, ce
qu'il va amener avec lui c'est
le bagage et tous les trucs et
les comparables avec les joueurs
pour essayer de chercher le plus
d'argent possible ses clients il
va êtr ça du
côté patronal si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi pour négocier
les contrats et le
aussi alors ça mène une atout
supplémentaire aussi.
- Comment voyez-vous la
direction bicéphale à deux têtes
parce que Jeff Gorton sera son
patron hiérarchique pensait le
président, n'ont pas laissé
l'autonomie.
Il y a deux documents remplaçant
alors.
- On n'a jamais vu ça avec le
Canadien de Montréal, on a vu ça
avec plusieurs zones inquiets
pour le directeur général sera
porté à un patron qui connaît le
acquis, je ne peux rien et à
Monsieur Mousseline, mais Jeff
Gorton doit se rapportait à lui
et ce n'est pas undu hockey, onr
travailler ensemble et prendre
les décisions ensemble
également.qui pensent que c'estn
yes Man, c'est qu'on le connaît
si on dit ça
de lui.
utres qu'outres qu'outres qu'oun
avait envisagés, Brière et
Patrick Roy?
Est-ce que dans le
ne le connaissais bien et il
savait que sa lettre lui?
- C'est sûr qu'il avait un pas
en avant parce que quand on veut
créer une chimie et une synergie
qu'on va prendre ses décisions
en équipe pour rebâtir cette
équipe-là, je sais qu'on aime
pas utiliser le mot rebâtir à
Montréal mais c'est le cas, on
peut paseuteuteuteuteuteuteuteut
seulement aller plus haut alors
on peut faire le travail
rapidement et quand on connaît
quelqu'un c'est plus facile de
commencer le travail.
- Parlez-moi de Pa
seconde, est-ce qu'il va se
trouver entraînant finalement?
On va tout d'abord pour le même
prix?
- Je ne suis pas dans le secret
des dieux mais c'est sûr que
Patrick Roy à la faveur du
public et laisse personne
indifférente et on aimerait la
voir à Montréal mais ça ne veut
pas dire que Patrick ne pourra
errière lerrière lerrière lerrie
banc du Canadien de Montréal.
- ce ne serait pas la
combinaison parfaite?
Les deux qui vont chercher les
meilleurs joueurs puis Monsieur
Mousseline qui regardent cela
d'en haut et qui est content.
- Ça serait extraordinaire parce
que ce qu'il a démontré ses clés
bons avec les autres jeunes
joueurs il faut comprendre que
même si les joueurs arrivent
dans la Ligue nationale il y a
toujours l'aspect des jeunes
joueurs donc Patrick fera un bon
entraîneur à Montréal six sur.
- Vous l'avez dit pour rebâtir
le club ça ne peut pas les plus
bas.
- On doit absolument rebâtir la
première chose qu'il doit faire
en arrivant avec Jeff Gorton
c'est de regarder tous les
joueurs de l'organisation à
partir de Carey Price jusqu'au
joueur qu'on a repêché jusqu'au
dernier repêchage on va devoir
régler le problème de Logan
Mailloux qui était le premier
choix du Canadien de Montréal
qui n'a pas fait l'unanimité on
va devoir régler ce dossier-là
et éventuellement dans un avenir
moyennement rapproché quel
joueur on veut avoir dans la
formation d'ici de trois ans?
Et si on n'est pas capable de
les avoir difficiles de trois
ans je pense qu'il est temps de
faire le ménage et
malheureusement ça inclut
d'enlever Carey Price il va
avoir des grosses décisions à
prendre.
- Oui parce qu'il coûte che